m
bonjour
quand on m'a demandé d'intervenir à
athènes aujourd'hui sur
le thème de nos différences j'ai fait le
même constat que vous
je suis en blouse et vous ne l'êtes pas
car le scientifique est toujours en
brousse
c'est bien connu qu ils vous vendent du
danseur ou des yaourts
des voitures ou des produits numériques
de la lessive de l'eau radioactive ou
des cigarettes il est toujours en
bluetooth
je suis désolé les scientifiques sont
pas toujours en blues ils ont leurs
différences aussi
les différences se limite pas au port de
blues ou au non port de blues la plupart
du temps distingue les scientifiques par
leur spécialité
et en bioinformatique
on ne porte pas de blouse
justement ces différences ces
spécialités des chercheurs et des
biologistes des médecins des pharmaciens
les informaticiens les physiciens
et bien il y en a ils restent dans leur
micro cossement et surtout ils vont pas
se mélanger
et puis il ya une recherche qu'on dit
interdisciplinaire où
transdisciplinaires c'est de cette
recherche là que je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui
par exemple avec le programme fall dit
on va faire en plusieurs temps foldit
c'est quoi
c'est ce qu'on appelle
un jeu sérieux
c'est à dire c'est un jeu à but est de
pédagogique ou scientifique
c'est un jeu qui gratuits disponibles
tout le monde peut le télécharger les
collégiens peuvent y jouer
et ça va faire quoi et bien tout le
monde va pouvoir participer
à de la recherche scientifique on va
donc tirer parti des différences
dans la façon de penser dans la façon de
faire un geste dans la façon de proposer
les choses et on va travailler tous
ensemble
foldit c'est un programme qui a été
présenté à une telle x à vancouver fin
2012 donc je vais pas détailler mais en
gros
c'est un programme de simulation
moléculaire qui sert à sculpter des
protéines
alors qu'est ce que c'est la simulation
moléculaire
et bien ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire
ça sert à simuler des molécules
ah oui parce que les molécules on peut
pas les prendre en photo comme ça
même avec des très grands mikos
microscope les molécules se laisse pas
toujours prendre en photo il ya même des
fois des molécules qui se laissent pas
du tout prendre en photo
donc bah classiquement on utilise un
gros microscope ou d'autres techniques
et puis on résout la structure
tridimensionnelle en trois dimensions
d'une molécule ici une protéine et il y
à un paradigme très important biologie
c'est que si on connaît la forme d'une
molécule on sait à peu près à quoi elle
va servir ou comment elle fonctionne dit
qu'il ya une relation entre la structure
la forme et la fonction ce à quoi ça
sert
eh bien vous le dites si ça à ça si on
part d'une protéine dont on connaît pas
la forme est bien le joueur peut
sculpter la protéine même s'il n'a pas
de connaissances en biochimie ou en
chine on lui dit juste rapproche les
boules bleues des boules rouges évite
les piquants ya des piquants et toute
façon si on se trompe un scientifique en
blouse qui nous explique ce qu'il faut
faire
foldit
faut avouer les choses dont la
profession les scientifiques il n'y
croyais pas trop on va laisser jouer des
collégiens et puis ils vont sûrement
trouvé la solution que nous on trouve
pas
et bien 6
novembre 2012 des joueurs de foldit on
ne sait pas qui ils sont probablement
éparpillés au travers du monde c'est
juste qu'ils s'appellent les concasseurs
de vide
eh bien ils ont trouvé une solution que
les chercheurs n'avaient jamais trouvé
même avec leur super ordinateur qui
calcule toute la journée tout en tout
temps tout le temps ils ont trouvé
la structure d'une protéine du hiv
et ça faut savoir que souvent c'est un
pas de géant vers la compréhension ici
du sida est un pas de géant vers la
conception d'une nouvelle thérapie
donc
l'humain est toujours plus intelligent
que la machine
avec des collègues de paris nicolas
féret marque baden on a décidé dans la
même mouvance de concevoir un programme
qui s'appelle bio spring
lui non plus conçus pour essayer de
comprendre comment se structure les
molécules mais pour essayer plutôt de
comprendre comment elles s'associent
bon il faut savoir en faisant un petit
peu d'histoire si on reprend la
découverte des grandes structures des
biomolécules watson et crick pour la dnp
ruth pour la myoglobine et bien les
chercheurs déjà dans les années 40 50
il est de la modélisation moléculaire
il s'utilise des petites boules en bois
ou en métal des petites tiges en bois ou
en métal et puis hop il construisait et
puis ils faisaient bouger leurs modèles
moléculaire si ça coinçait 6 a coincé au
niveau physique
donc il avait déjà utilisation de la
modélisation moléculaire avant les
ordinateurs pour visualiser la molécule
dans son espace mais aussi pour essayer
de la triturer de la déformer un petit
peu comme foldit dans folle dit le
joueur il prend sa souris et puis il
tire un petit peu sur la protéine dans
tous les sens pour essayer de trouver
quelle forme replier et la plus stable
mais il manque un petit truc
on sent pas la souris quand ça coince
alors d'ambiance ring on a décidé plutôt
d'intégrer
de rajouter la sensation tactile en
utilisant ce petit outil s'appelle un
bras haptique
donc c'est une sorte de souris 3d mais
avec un retour d'effort si on fait un
geste
c'est le bon geste on va être guidés
vers ce geste doit être confortée dans
ce geste
si c'est pas le bon geste les petits
moteurs font que ça coince
exactement comme avec les modèles de
watson et crick il percute
alors ça c'est pas aussi simplement je
vous passe les détails pour vous dire
comment on modélise la molécule en gros
on réduit la molécule à débouler des
ressorts
et on a dit on a conçu ce programme
pour étude et plutôt les interactions
moléculaires c'est à dire que si on
rajoute la sensation tactile on se
retrouve exactement dans cette position
là
on essaie d'associer deux molécules
vous donner c'est un ordinateur pas de
problème il va trouver la solution
au bout d'un certain temps vous donner
ça à un enfant
mon fils de 4 ans y'a pas de problème
il aura fait une reconnaissance visuelle
de complémentarité de forme et lorsqu'il
va emboîter les deux objets y va sentir
sur le plan tactile
que c'est la bonne solution ce que
l'ordinateur ne pourra pas sentir
alors avec bios ring c'est exactement ça
on associe les molécules et on sent
quand c'est la bonne solution évidemment
on aurait pu imprimer les molécules en
3d si on apprenne imprimante 3d et puis
des associés le problème c'est que une
fois qu'on a un prix mais notre modèle
en 3d il est statique il bouge plus
c'est un chewing gum tout sec
avec un modèle avec des boules et des
ressorts même s'il est virtuel on peut
le déformer à volonté et ressentir quand
même la sensation tactile via le brave
tic
on l'a utilisé bio cycling récemment
dans l'équipe de rennes dans laquelle je
travaille la faculté de pharmacie et de
médecine à l'institut de génétique et
développement de rennes pour étudier
cette chose
qu'est ce donc
eh bien vous connaissez sûrement le
téléthon est donc vous connaissez la
myopathie
c'est une maladie qui touche
les enfants en bas âge qui perdent
usage de leurs muscles
pour simplifier c'est lié à cette
protéine en rouge que vous voyez
s'appelle la dystrophine et qui va faire
le lien entre
la membrane musculaire qui protège
l'intégrité du muscle qui est en bleu et
la structure du muscle qui est en verre
et si on n'a pas cette protéine qui fait
le lien entre les deux le muscle à force
de s'allonger et de se contracter va se
déchirer
et on va perdre la fonction du plus que
le problème c'est que pour bien
comprendre la maladie on a besoin de
comprendre la forme de la protéine
et cette protéine hla impossible de la
regarder avec des microscopes
ou des méthodes expérimentales qui vont
nous conduire à sa structure donc on va
faire de la simulation
et si on fait de la simulation sur un
dépôt appareil qu'on a en france le
synchrotron à paris
eh bien on obtient cette forme blanche
flou on a pas du tout de précisions donc
on va être amené à regagner en précision
grâce à la simulation pour essayer
d'imaginer comment notre protéines
idéalement les petites boules là vont
rentrer dans cette formule en
détail un petit peu d'où vient ce modèle
bleu vert jaune et bien c'est la forme
de la protéine que l'ordinateur tout
seul après dit voyez qu'on est loin de
ce qu'on a mesurée au synchrotron on a
quelque chose qui est beaucoup plus
torturé eh bien le programme bio spring
va nous aider cette fois ci non plus
associer deux molécules l'une à l'autre
et de ressentir lorsqu'on a la bonne
solution mais d'associer la molécule à
son propre fantôme à sa silhouette
essayez de sculpter la protéine en temps
réel
c'est ce que je me propose de vous faire
je suis désolé j'ai pas des petits
personnages qui vont venir déguisé
donc voilà j'utilise le brave tic et je
vais guidée très simplement
la molécule dans l' enveloppe je donne
cinq collégiens n'y a pas de problème
ils trouvent la solution voit bien qu'il
ya une banane qu'il a une tige à faire
rentrer dans la banane qui peut le
mettre dans les deux sens il va tester
les deux sens hélas
en simplifiant en quelque sorte le
dispositif qui me permet de faire de la
résolution structurale de découvrir la
structure de la molécule eh bien
je vais pouvoir
permettre à des néophytes n'importe qui
d'entre vous à des collégiens donc le
dispositif a été testé au festival des
sciences à rennes
et ça ça va me permettre de faire quoi
pas au lieu de faire mois 50 fois la
simulation dans la journée je pouvoir la
mettre à disposition de différentes
personnes qui vont pouvoir faire ça chez
eux en rentrant du travail ou chez eux
entre les cours ou chez eux pendant les
courses il sèche
et puis à la fin j'aurais 2003 2000 3000
4000 5000 fois le geste qui aurait été
un petit peu différent un petit peu
varié chacun aura sa solution
personnelle au puzzle 3d que je vais lui
proposer
et finalement je vais obtenir
un nombre de solutions suffisant qui
permettra de me dire sur le plan
statistique j'ai à peu près tester
toutes les possibilités je vais gagner
du temps parce que si je donne à un
ordinateur il va commencer parmi les
associés comme ça et là ça marchera pas
en quelques secondes on a une solution
qui est à peu près adéquat on a donc pu
résoudre la structure de la protéine
dystrophine ces derniers mois à rennes
pour la première fois alors nos
différences
quelle différence
tout le monde peut faire de la recherche
scientifique tout le monde peut résoudre
la structure de protéines il suffit
juste d'avoir un dispositif
simplifié
avec un petit peu technologie
pour pouvoir mettre à disposition
ce jeu là c'est une première brique sepa
foldit mais c'est une première brique
vers un jeu sérieux
mais de sa disposition de tout le monde
et alors nos différences quelle belle
différence on va tous faire un geste
différent on va tous trouver des
solutions différentes on va être sûr de
balayer toutes les possibilités et de ne
pas louper la solution c'est ça la
différence
merci